[Music]
jacob starts off this hour in
chattanooga hi jacob welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up man
so my wife and i are 27
we've been in our home for
about a year and a half now but we've
just been listening to your show for
about a year
so we're trying to figure out if we
should refinance our home from a 30 year
to 15
um based on where we are right now
no
if you pay a 30 like a 15
it pays off in 15.
now you would refinance it either way
and while you're at it put it on a 15 if
you can save enough on the interest for
that to make sense yeah and what we talk
about with refinancing is doing a break
even analysis which just means figuring
out when you're going to roi on this
decision so what's your current interest
rate
um 3.5 3.5 on the 30-year what would you
go down to if you did the 15
um i think it would just barely bump
down if not stay the same
yeah at that point it's not no it'd be
more like 2.5 right now
i mean the rates this week on 15 will be
around two and a half so you'd save
around one percent what's your balance
120 okay all right so if you save one
percent that's 1200 bucks
a year
if the refinance cost is 3 600 bucks it
takes three years to recoup that's what
george talking about of a ba of a
break-even analysis if you're saving 200
but if you're saving twelve hundred
dollars it takes twenty four hundred
dollars to refinance then you recoup in
two years you're following me
yep i got you but you don't have to do
any of that you could run those numbers
out if you want with churchill mortgage
and see where you stand
it's borderline i doubt it's going to
make sense i would imagine your closing
costs are going to make this break even
too far out to make it to make it fun
with with the spread that you've got
because it might not be 2 5 it might be
275 which changes it from 1200 down to
about 900 and now it gets less you know
lengthens that breakeven time out there
you don't want to break even time much
more in two years
it doesn't make sense so the
the answer to big answer your question
is you don't have to refinance just to
go to a 15 you just start get your
calculator out and your your payment
calculator at ramseysolutions.com and do
the payment on 120 000 at three
and a half percent on 15 years
and then through the payment principal
interest only at three and a half figure
out what your exact principal and
interest is
and then the difference you pay that as
extra principal every month which is
making you basically pay a 15-year
payment you see what i'm doing
yeah that's what we mean and it pays off
in exactly as if you'd done a 15 year
yeah and a lot of people dave you know
obviously we recommend only getting a 15
year if you've already done the 30
that's okay it's usually not worth
undoing that decision unless you have an
unusually high interest rate or there's
some other factors at play but
i love the spirit of it i can tell that
you guys want to do this plan and so the
best thing you can do is start to make
double triple mortgage payments and get
that thing paid off in 15 years or less
yeah because here's the thing you're not
really gonna run that extra 15 very long
if you're working the baby steps
because when you get to baby steps four
five and six you're putting 15 of your
income away to retirement you're doing
kids college and then any extra you have
you're throwing at the mortgage it's not
just the 15-year upgrade right and so
the 15-year upgrade but only apply while
you're working uh one through
uh three and i might not even do it then
i probably just use that to work one
through three and just let it sit at 30
if you're if you're there so uh
you know that
so you really never actually do this
because you're gonna put more than the
extra upgrade in baby step six when
you're working baby step six